[Applause]
oh yeah he's guilty right oh yeah
i think the big story here is black
lives matter la or black lives matter
posting that they still
can't side with the chicago police
department they still support jesse and
he's been a vocal uh advocate and he's
been out front and then they will we can
never side with the chicago pd
you never side with any police
department especially not chicago and
they bring up a lot of [ __ ] up history
but that got nothing to do with this the
reason history is [ __ ] made up a
hate crime
and i i think they miscalculated because
the public perception
is yo i'm dumb done with black lives
matter seems that's what i'm seeing you
saw carlos carlos's tweet yeah when
carlos miller is tweeting that kind of
[ __ ] you know you [ __ ] up brandon
watch if you are black and cause miller
is outwardly saying you i don't [ __ ]
with you you're you're [ __ ] what do
you say he's like uh they stole all that
money and did nothing for us yeah i'm
going to remember that or something like
oh remember that something like that
yeah remember that black lives matter
stole all that money and nothing's
changed
yeah
and i even saw an opinion piece in uh i
think it was newsweek written from maybe
he's a professor emeritus or something
at brooklyn college we know newsweek to
be fairly liberal probably definitely
professors i know to be fairly liberal
and he was like black lives matter
really missed a mark with this
not just defending jesse smallay but
like i i forget the other thing they
said oh he's like this guy's guilty of a
crime and the fact that you can defend
that is crazy and to see a white
professor in brooklyn publicly say that
yeah you just discredit your whole
platform and you make it so emotional so
now it looks like all of your all of
your facts or arguments are based on
that emotion and you can't be taken like
because people do things that are wrong
yeah right like you just have to be
willing to admit that like if there's
somebody from your community that you
want to support does something wrong you
have to be able to hold them accountable
so that people can trust that your
your decision making
if you were going to be a leader
yeah that your decision-making is on
point yeah like
to come out and say listen this is
really [ __ ] up what you did
and
you discredit
the plight of black people in america by
doing things like this because there are
so many instances of racism that happen
and now those can potentially be
discredited by you faking this thing and
you can use the same examples you use
like fred hampton to say these are
people who actually had you discredit
them as well yeah because now people who
do get mistreated by the police
department you're going to look at them
a little bit more skeptically we don't
support what he did that's all you got
to do that's it it sounds like they're
just riding for their boy though [ __ ]
that bro but that's like the chris cuomo
thing we're talking about last week
you're not family uh yeah you're not
family and you chris cuomo is a news guy
who's helping his friend and he's
shading the lines of what ethical
journalism is you are an advocacy group
your entire purpose is to change and
help chris cuomo is an entertainer
black lives matter is outwardly the most
morally righteous we are trying to help
our people at all costs and then all the
little whispers that we would kind of be
like it's weird a little bit did they
say like i want to justify i want to
abolish the nuclear family and this and
that all of that you can point to now
and justifiably be like these people are
out of their minds mm-hmm yeah you're
giving ammunition to your opposition yes
but it seems like they're just not
trying to they don't really care about
consistency they're just like we're
siding with whatever the black cause is
that's why you look at the credibility
you go with but they could have chose to
not say anything that's the other thing
you could just be silent you could not
say anything you could say we side on we
are on the side of justice and there is
constantly injustice done to our people
however in this case justice is not with
him
that's the really like oh that's if they
did that i'd be like that's dope good
for them
yeah but now i don't trust it and [ __ ]
bro carlos miller not a guy that's going
to tweet this yeah yeah he didn't say it
to me on a private text he tweeted that
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i guess i've never really seen them
i've just always seen them on the side
of like black empowerment and like i've
never really seen them on like the side
of even empowerment should not blindly
support everything no matter how wrong
it is yeah i don't disagree but to me
it's not like unexpected that's like um
pitying that's like coddling yeah that's
not empowering at all yeah i mean we
talked about this before like i think
the most effective thing if blm wanted
to get white people on board and show
all the police brutality that against
what they've done against white people
yeah they'd be like yo we're all in this
together against [ __ ] up policing and
systemic racism like let's all get
together yeah but they don't do that
because then that would be an all lives
matter argument right and they'd have to
yeah they'd have to admit that all lives
matter
and their thing is the sole focus on
black people in the black plate in
america but that would be very effective
to their goal yeah but clearly there's
not a lot of like logic or reasoning at
the head of this movement or at least
the one in is it specifically los
angeles or is it according to tmz i'm
reading here it says blm and blm la
released a statement before the verdict
in support of the empire actor yeah this
is a shame
so but it seems to me like they're just
calculating they're like yeah we just
are going to [ __ ] with black people no
matter what no matter what the truth is
no matter what it doesn't matter
whatever black people are doing we [ __ ]
with that yeah you just discredit the
whole brand what do you think al yeah
i'm not for that it's like even people
from my community if you're doing wrong
you call it out yeah because that's how
you improve your community right or stay
silent and i would probably stay silent
for family and i think for friends i'd
be like nah that's [ __ ] wild
especially if i am an advocacy group if
you're asking me if one of y'all [ __ ]
up i'm gonna be like i'm riding with my
boy but i am never an advocate yeah i'm
the i'm the last advocate how do you
listen to
and take the advice of a group that is
admitting to you they're willing to just
lie or overlook the truth yeah to
support the people that have supported
them
like like how do you actually have like
a serious conversation with a politician
like you're walking into a room and
they're just looking at you and they're
like yeah yeah i mean i don't think
cosby did it
yeah right you're just like wait wait it
feels like bad for you and i'll tell you
like like can i take anything else
serious that you say on your mind
by doing this by supporting jesse's
jesse smallay black lives matter the
organization tune on they're queuing on
they have done the biggest service they
did and they have done the biggest
disservice to black lives matter the
movement because now whenever somebody
tweets hashtag black lives matter you're
not going to associate it with the fact
that black people are being killed by
cops disproportionately this is [ __ ]
up right systemic racism all that you're
gonna you have the exit ramp up oh you
know what that's an organization that
won't even [ __ ] call out their office
i'm gonna [ __ ] about that you look
ridiculous having a black lives matter
hashtag you have an off-ramp that's
great you just dismissed your tickets
yeah just dismiss it we just need the
exit ramp excellent take it all the time
i need the exit ramp for caring that's
it right there now they have they have
done more to undercut the black lives
matter movement than anything they did
before that to help it yeah
yeah that's arguable but that's a
feeling i they definitely did a lot to
hurt it
you're not tweeting black lives matter
right now that's true i heard that you
think alienates even like liberal white
people that are on board with them
like it's in my opinion conservatives
are already alienated from them from
europe yeah i think it makes it a little
bit harder for liberal whites now
definitely the moderates
moderates are looking at it now and
they're not going to be educated enough
a lot of them to separate the movement
from the organization they're gonna be
like oh nice organization this whole
movement is just it's just gone it's
nonsense yeah
you